- We need to start with a big congrats.
I don't know if anybody,
everybody knows, but last month,
you said that you'd been
undergoing cancer treatment
for a year, which I didn't know about,
so I don't know that
many people knew about.
- You were not supposed
to know about it.
- Yeah, I was like,
I don't think many people knew about.
- I kept it quiet.
- You did.
- Yes.
- And you got the news
that you're now cancer free, right?
- I am.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- [Terry] Thank you.
- That's a hard thing
to keep quiet.
- I...
Listen.
- [Kelly] Just physically
while you're working.
- Yeah, it is.
It was hard.
The thing was, I didn't
wanna say anything.
I don't want pity and I
don't have a publicist
that you released it and everybody says,
oh my God, Kelly's, oh, you
know, I didn't want that.
That happens.
- Yeah.
- I just wanted to keep it quiet.
My family knew.
And then as you can tell,
I'm a little subconscious
about my appearance
but that's from the treatments
and people were saying,
what's wrong with me?
What's wrong with me?
And so finally I thank Fox
for allowing me the time to say -
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In November I was diagnosed
with bladder cancer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I went on treatments
at Baylor, I mean Baylor,
Yale Medical Center up
in New Haven, Connecticut
for six weeks.
Then I came back and was diagnosed
weeks later, cancer free.
But I still do follow up treatments
which I still have to go back up for that.
- Which are hard on your body.
- You have no idea.
I had no idea.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause it was,
it's bladder cancer.
And then in March I'm getting ready to go
to Hawaii and I'm all excited
I get a vacation after,
well over two years and I was
having trouble with my neck
and I go in, my wife says,
we need to get that checked.
And then they found a tumor here.
So that's Merkel cell cancer.
- Oh my God.
- That's a form
of skin cancer.
It's relatively rare,
had it not been for this
then we wouldn't have found that.
- [Kelly] Yeah they didn't catch it.
- So they cut all that out
and now my face is a little,
I'm self-conscious.
My wife says, you look fine.
But -
- Yeah, I gotta be honest
with you, it just isn't out, yeah.
- If I had -
- [Kelly] I didn't know.
- But you know what Kelly,
it's like I'm so
self-conscious of my face.
One good thing about it though,
I don't have to shave 'cause
I have no hair over here.
So it was, it's been a long battle.
And then I went back to MD Anderson
and got, I'm cancer free here.
So as we do this interview.
- [Kelly] Jeez.
- What a blessing though, yeah.